welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with the last
of us part two making big waves on the
Internet
due to its incredible new trailer I
thought it was time to dive into the
game and break down everything that we
know so far about the upcoming title
throughout this video I'm gonna be going
over everything that you need to know
about the sequel including its release
state storyline and whether Joel is
alive or dead now there are potentially
heavy spoilers here so if you want to go
into the game at blinder than a clicker
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of
everything we know so far about the Last
of Us part two okay so the first thing
that you need to know is that the Last
of Us part 2 releases on the 21st of
February 2020 the game is exclusively on
PlayStation 4 and though it was
initially thought that this may be a PS
5 launch title we can confirm that it
will be available on current hardware
the game is said to pretty much
encompass the 35 year history of Naughty
Dog the studio behind it and is being
labeled by many that work at the company
as their proudest achievement this is of
course a grand statement as over the
last three decades the studio has
created several masterpieces including
the crash bandicoot series jak and
daxter games and of course the Uncharted
franchise so naturally it's reasonable
to be pretty hyped about the upcoming
release the Last of Us part 2 itself
takes place 5 years after the initial
game and 25 years after the first
outbreak of the cordyceps the world has
decayed even further with the remainders
of humanity's scattered into tribes
we're crossing paths with the wrong one
can lead to instant death Ellie who is
14 in the prior game is now 19 and has
been adjusting to life in Tommy's colony
which is where we last left her in the
prior entry whilst we don't get
confirmation of this it is heavily
hinted that similar to what was paid
lip-service to in the prior game Joel
and Tommy have had another falling-out
and because of it the former has left
the camp whilst this isn't confirmed we
don't see him in any of the footage set
at the colony and the prior relationship
between the two
suggest that Joel may have left them
Ellie decided to stay for one reason or
another and she is gone on to live a
pretty quote/unquote normal life in the
original gameplay trailer that was
released last year we did learn that
Ellie had apparently been adopted as she
had someone referred to as an old man
that hated her going out on scavenging
hunts it's a pretty safe assumption to
make that this is Tommy and this could
also be a reason that added to Joel's
departure in the trailer we also saw the
characters slowly developing a
relationship with another member of her
camp named Dina now we do know that the
virus that she carries and is immune to
can't be passed on through kissing and
that the camp also seemed unaware of her
infection in the recently released
trailer we learned that Ellie care
deeply about Dina and that during the
aforementioned scavenging hunt Dina is
apparently killed right in front of her
by another band of humans whilst we
don't get a full confirmation of this I
think it's a pretty safe bet to assume
that she is and it becomes clear that
Ellie is out on a quest for revenge
by the looks of it Ellie is badly beaten
by the other camp but somehow she
manages to escape and heads back to
Tommy to arm up and head out after them
it's clear that Ellie wants to murder
them all and she just doesn't care about
how big the group is or how far she has
to travel the game appears to be set
around her making her way across the
United States on the trail of the
bandits in order to bring them all to an
end one way or another now on her
adventures at some point on the trail
she comes across Joel who is very much
alive and breathing and has probably
spent some time surviving surviving I
can't do the voice anyway in the prior
gameplay footage it was heavily
theorized that Joel was in fact dead and
that his presence in the trailer was
simply a hallucination by Ellie in order
to voice what she was going through and
what her thought process was this picked
up a lot of traction with fans pretty
much agonizing over the first look frame
by frame trying to decipher exactly what
was going on and the real fate of the
character however this new trailer
pretty much 100% confirms that Joel is
alive and well well as well as you can
be in the world of The Last of Us and
whilst there are some people sticking
strongly to the ghost Joel theory in the
trailer he covers Ellie's mouth and
grabs her whilst holding her back which
I'm yet to see a ghost do
see a ghost do anything really but never
mind
the last of us though horror related
seems to steer clear of the supernatural
so things are looking good in terms of
the character being fully alive and who
knows we may even get to play as him
once more during the game
either way Ellie is going to need all of
the help that she can get as we see in
the trailer that there are a lot of
terrifying new enemies including
infected dogs and further mutated humans
the infected look even more terrifying
and who knows this game it might be
better trying to avoid them completely
rather than attempting to go
head-to-head with them as always though
humans are just as big a threat and this
is going to be the main driving force of
the campaign in addition to this though
we don't have full confirmation it's
safe to assume that multiplayer will be
back as well the Last of Us multiplayer
was a big aspect of the original game
and there's a lot of potential here for
some amazing death matches in the
arena's of the world all in all the game
is shaping up to be another masterpiece
by the studio and there's a wealth of
potential here for Naughty Dog to once
more knock this out of the park
Ashley Johnson is back as Ellie Troy
Baker is back as Joel and overall this
is looking like another classic The Last
of Us was and is still my favorite game
and I really can't wait to see what
happens in part 2 when it releases next
year now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the Last of Us part 2 and if
you're as hyped for the game as I am
coming below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out my breakdown of
the best MCU Easter Egg that you missed
throughout all of the Marvel films from
Iron Man to avengers endgame it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want something else to watch after this
so I'll leave that linked at the end of
this video if you want to come chat to
me about movies TV shows games and comic
books then make sure you follow me on
Twitter at Definition whitey it's the
best way to get in touch with me and is
the perfect place to suggest new videos
and content so hopefully I see you over
there after this well so just one let
you know that we're currently giving
away a free copy of spider-man far from
home on blu-ray and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is to
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the Last of Us part 2 in the
comments section below the winner will
be chosen at random on October the 15th
and the blu-ray will be shipped out from
the intricate surprise
best of luck to everyone he takes part
this channel for people who were mad
into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]